y
[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 en
mi armar la junta militar amenazó con
más represión después de un fin de
semana de protestas en donde murieron
dos personas en enfrentamientos con los
militares la unión europea estudia
posibles sanciones contra el país
mientras que la onu pide detener la
represión a la ciudadanía tenemos
análisis en esta misión de noticias
los ministros de exteriores de la unión
europea estudian posibles sanciones
contra rusia por sus violaciones a los
derechos humanos en rechazo a la condena
de dos años y medio contra el líder
opositor ruso alexéi navalni la medida
llega después de agotar el diálogo
diplomático entre bruselas y moscú
tenemos reporte desde bruselas
y la fabricante de aviones boeing y la
afe recomendaron suspender los vuelos de
los aviones se ponen triples siete
equipados con motores pratt and whitney
4000 esto después del incidente bajo
investigación que tuvo un avión de estas
características operados por united
airlines que se vio obligado a regresar
a tierra
muy buenos días bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález vamos a comenzar con una
noticia que está en desarrollo en este
momento luca atanasio embajador de
italia en la república democrática del
congo fue asesinado en un aparente
ataque contra un convoy de delegados de
la organización de naciones unidas allí
en este país africano vamos a ir hasta
roma en italia y esta natale mendoza
para conocer reacciones en este país
europeo y también para conocer la
información preliminar de esta noticia
en desarrollo muy buenos dias natalia
muy buenas tardes para ustedes la
capital italiana y detalles de lo que ha
ocurrido allí en la república
democrática del congo y reacciones en
italia
pues según elementos comunicados en una
nota oficial de la cancillería italiana
el embajador italiano en república
democrática del congo luca atanasio se
encontraba a bordo de un vehículo que
hacía parte de un convoy de las naciones
unidas en la zona de la ciudad de goma
en cuando con el viajaba un carabinero
militar italiano el convoy fue atacado
no se sabe todavía por parte de qué
grupo fue atacado él en el hecho del
embajador y su acompañante en los dos
italianos murieron la prensa italiana
evoca un intento de secuestro de este
convoy el ministro italiano de asuntos
exteriores
witty dimaggio ha reaccionado
oficialmente a través de un comunicado
oficial en el cual deplora lo sucedido y
manifiesta su profundo dolor por la
muerte del embajador y de su acompañante
seguramente las próximas horas habremos
tendremos más detalles sobre las
circunstancias de este drama
natalia complemento su información
diciendo que esta ciudad de goma es una
ciudad fuertemente disputada por grupos
rebeldes están
frontera con uganda y ruanda donde
justamente hay también disputas con
grupos rebeldes por ser una zona minera
donde extracción de minas y de manera
ilegal y es una zona fuertemente
custodiada por los convoyes de la
organización de naciones unidas una
noticia en desarrollo más adelante
volveremos con ustedes romá si hay más
reacciones por parte del gobierno
italiano o del organismo de naciones
unidas gracias por este reporte desde
romana tal ya vamos con otro tema
destacado de la jornada nuevamente miles
de personas volvieron a tomarse las
calles de las principales ciudades de
mianmar en una jornada de huelga general
para protestar contra la junta militar
que amenazó con más muertes esto después
de un fin de semana de protestas en el
que perdieron la vida dos personas
debido a la represión policial el pleno
de la unión europea también está
estudiando posibles sanciones que
podrían poner a la junta militar que
tomó el poder mientras que en las
naciones unidas- desde allí en ginebra-
pidieron a los militares detener la
represión ciudadana y también regresar a
la senda democrática llamados de la
comunidad internacional que parecen que
no tienen eco entre los golpistas en
mianmar para analizar este tema
y sobre cómo la comunidad internacional
está manejando la crisis política en
mianmar hemos invitado a alejandro godoy
él es especialista en relaciones
hemisféricas occidentales también es
experto en relaciones económicas y
políticas del continente asiático señor
godoy gracias por estar con nosotros
nuevamente aquí en france 24 un gusto
saludarlo y comienzo por preguntarle me
armar esta próxima ya cumplir un mes
desde la fecha que tuvo lugar el golpe
militar la represión y el rompimiento
democrático que es lo que hemos visto a
lo largo de estos días porque la
comunidad internacional más allá de
condenar estos hechos no actúa
pero que seguir hacia santiago es
importante precisar que obviamente por
todo los militares han aprovechado todo
el contexto de lo que vivimos en la
pandemia y por ende si bien han
condenado a eeuu la unión europea
otras naciones de asia han establecido
que es importante hablar de este tema
que potencialmente en el futuro se
pueden dar un bloqueo económico sin
embargo están atados un poco por todo lo
que están viviendo al interior de los
estados y los militares saben que es un
momento que pueden aprovechar muy bien
algo que preocupa además muchísimo es
todo el tema base que podría llevarse a
cabo esta semana unas manifestaciones
aún mayores de aquellas que se dieron en
1988 conocida como los 48 es decir 8 de
agosto de 1988 ya con dos personas
fallecidas el corte de las
comunicaciones internet entre otros
temas pues es un escenario que es una
bomba de tiempo no solamente a nivel
asiático sino a nivel internacional y
recordemos que básicamente al interior
del mismo pues tenemos el caso de los
y esa etnia musulmana que también
implica un desarrollo fuerte señor godo
y estas posibles sanciones que está
estudiando la unión europea para imponer
a la junta militar que está gobernando
ahora de facto en mianmar qué efecto
tendrían y podrían ser de pronto un
primer paso para que otros actores
internacionales sigan el mismo camino
para presionar a los militares
eso se espera ya de por sí el líder
militar que ha dado este golpe de estado
se supone que podría entablar en los
próximos años algunos juicios en la
corte penal internacional dado que ha
sido él el líder ian mind con todo el
tema base de la represión a los
rohingyas y esperaríamos por supuesto
que se dieran unas condenas adicionales
y que pudiera generar un efecto dominó
en todo lo que tiene que ver con este
golpe de estado y rápidamente porque
sanciones y no los canales diplomáticos
muy cierto precisamente porque como lo
que vemos es en mi amar desde hace
muchos años una diplomacia y una
democracia que ha estado en riesgo y que
no ha sido completamente ada es una de
las razones más fuertes que encontramos
en porque no se puede dar estos canales
base sino más la represión y la sanción
esa sería como la gran conclusión por el
momento alejandro godoy desde la ciudad
de bogotá muchas gracias por haber
explicado este tema para la audiencia de
france 24
seguimos con otros temas los ministros
de exteriores de la unión europea
también están estudiando la posibilidad
de acordar un paquete de sanciones
contra rusia similares a las que ya ha
impuesto a eeuu para castigar las
violaciones a los derechos humanos de
esta manera a bruselas espera actuar de
frente para mostrar su rechazo por la
detención al líder opositor alexéi
navalni que fue condenado a dos años y
medio de prisión y que también en el
pasado tuvo que ser atendido en alemania
por envenenamiento se trata de la
primera vez que la unión europea
utilizaría este régimen de sanciones
ligados a violaciones de los derechos
humanos la medida llega después
y los canales diplomáticos con la visita
a moscú de josep borrell el alto
representante de la política exterior de
la unión europea precisamente vamos allí
a bruselas
esther herrera nos amplía más detalles
en el siguiente reporte desde la capital
belga
tras el reciente y polémico viaje del
jefe de la diplomacia europea se recurre
a moscú los cancilleres europeos están
reunidos hoy en bruselas para abordar
futuras sanciones de nuevo a rusia la
detención y envenenamiento del líder
opositor alexéi navalni ha hecho pensar
a los países europeos que ahora mismo la
deriva autoritaria de rusia no tiene
marcha atrás por ello se están
estudiando nuevas sanciones contra altos
cargos del gobierno aunque algunos
países sobre todo del este están
pidiendo también que se incluya a
oligarcas rusos cercanos al presidente
ruso vladimir putin pero es algo que
ahora mismo no se tiene consenso sobre
esta cuestión no sea primera vez que la
unión europea aplicaría sanciones a
rusia y ha ocurrido por ejemplo con la
elección de la península de crimea
considerada ilegal por la unión europea
también sobre la guerra del este de
ucrania y se trataría sobre todo de
evitar la entrada a territorio europeo
de estas personas sancionadas o la
congelación de bienes a pesar de que las
relaciones entre la unión europea y
rusia- estar
más tensas que nunca bruselas insiste en
que hay que mantener la puerta abierta
al diálogo con rusia dejamos a europa
cruzamos el atlántico y vamos hasta eeuu
el fabricante aeronáutico boeing y
recomendó a las aerolíneas suspender los
vuelos de los aviones del modelo boeing
triple siete equipados con motores pratt
and whitney 4000 esto después de que un
avión de estas características operados
por la aerolínea united airlines
sufriera un incidente en una de sus
turbinas que obligó a que la tripulación
declarara la emergencia y regresará con
este avión a tierra n core a las
aerolíneas hacia na y corean air
anunciaron que por decisión propia ya
dejarían en tierra este tipo de
aeronaves equipados con estos motores en
particular mientras que japón también le
recomendó este tipo de medidas similares
a los operadores allí en el archipiélago
un espectáculo extraño para los testigos
pero un problema más grave para el
fabricante de aviones boeing ha
recomendado detener los vuelos de
ciertos aviones 777 después de que los
escombros del mismo tipo de avión
cayeran sobre la ciudad de denver él
estaba con su motor fallo poco después
del despegue recomendamos y apoyamos la
suspensión de las operaciones de los 69
27 77 en servicio y los 59 en
almacenamiento que son propulsados por
motores pratt and whitney 4000 112
mientras la investigación de la junta
nacional de seguridad en el transporte
está en curso
el vuelo 328 se dirigía a honolulu con
241 personas a bordo cuando fallo su
motor derecho pudo dar la vuelta y
aterrizar de forma segura y no se
reportaron heridos ni a bordo ni en
tierra en los peores 20 minutos
solamente estaba rezando y dije esto no
puede ser el anuncio de boeing se
produjo horas después de que el
organismo de aviación de eeuu ordenará
inspecciones adicionales a aviones
boeing 777 con el mismo motor que el del
vuelo 320
mientras tanto el ministerio de
transporte de japón ordenó a japan
airlines y anna suspender los vuelos de
aviones boeing 777 hasta nuevo aviso un
llamado al que se sumaron las dos
principales aerolíneas surcoreanas el
incidente supone un nuevo golpe para
boeing el 737 max del fabricante quedó
en tierra en todo el mundo en marzo de
2019 después de que 346 personas
murieran en dos accidentes debido a un
sistema de manejo de vuelo defectuoso
vamos a seguir en eeuu este país se
acerca al umbral de los 500 mil muertos
por el cob y 19 a pesar de haber
comenzado un intenso programa de
vacunación a escala nacional el país se
mantiene como el más afectado por el
coronavirus a nivel mundial con la mayor
cantidad de contagios y de personas
fallecidas
alva santana tiene los detalles en el
siguiente informe
muy cerca de otro doloroso hito para
eeuu hace un año cuando el virus apenas
hacía su aparición en el territorio el
entonces presidente prometía un rápido
regreso a la normalidad va a desaparecer
un día es como un milagro desaparecerá
pero muy pronto nueva york se convirtió
en epicentro de contagios en el país el
sistema sanitario y las funerarias
estaban colapsadas los trabajadores de
salud al límite
yo no quiero disculparme porque estoy
haciéndolo lo mejor que puedo pero si no
es suficiente lo siento mucho realmente
lo siento
una escena que pronto se extendió a toda
la nación muchos estados se mostraron
reticentes a adoptar cierres y
restricciones y en un año electoral el
porte de mascarillas se convirtió en un
símbolo de una postura política hay fila
y media
creo que quizás hemos fallado a la gente
al no conseguir que todo el mundo se
sume y creo que la reticencia por
adoptar la decisión de llevar tapabocas
y proteger a todo el mundo es un
mecanismo de supervivencia acting a one
donald trump contrajo y superó el virus
pero su pobre manejo de la pandemia fue
un factor clave para que los
estadounidenses confiarán en joe biden
para traer un nuevo enfoque desde la
casa blanca tuyo
para curar debemos recordar a veces es
difícil recordar pero así es como
sanamos y concentrado en la esperanza
que traen las vacunas eeuu y aplicado
más de 60 millones de dosis casi un 20
por ciento de su población sin embargo
el panorama aún es sombrío el instituto
de métricas y evaluaciones de salud
estima que más de 615 mil personas
podrían haber muerto para junio vamos a
finalizar esta emisión de noticias en
haití en el caribe este país vivió un
fin de semana de manifestaciones
ciudadanas para demandar la renuncia del
presidente juvenil moix el mandatario
recuerden que decidió permanecer en el
poder pese a que el calendario electoral
ya indicaba el fin de su mandato de
cinco años el pasado 7 de febrero las
calles de puerto príncipe que ven
ustedes en sus imágenes es la capital de
este país fueron el escenario de
enfrentamientos entre la policía local y
los ciudadanos quienes han recibido el
respaldo por parte de partidos de la
oposición también del empresariado
haitiano e incluso de la iglesia todos
exigen la dimisión del mandatario que
por su cuenta cuenta con el apoyo de la
organización de estados américanos y de
eeuu los enfrentamientos según los
reportes iniciales no dejaron heridos ni
víctimas mortales según lo indican
también los medios locales
[Música]
es todo por el momento aquí en las
noticias de france 24 pero recuerde que
usted puede mantenerse actualizado dando
un vistazo a nuestra página web france24
puntocom también accediendo a las redes
sociales y por supuesto descargando la
aplicación de france 24 en su teléfono
móvil para estar al tanto de los hechos
que ocurren en américa latina y al mundo
nos dejamos con nuestra programación
feliz día
[Música]